- But has your family started
giving you parenting advice
since you're now..
- Uh, yeah, you know...
Well, 'cause the funny
thing is I have 20 nieces
and nephews.
- Holy, Christmas must be hell.
- Yeah. It's crazy
It's crazy, yes, but it's fun.
Like, I've seen a lot
of my nieces and nephews
through different stages of their lives.
- Yeah.
- But obviously it's entirely
different when it's yours, so.
But I've got somewhat of an experience,
except for the diaper changing part, but.
- That's easy. People, like,
it's not hard. It's easy.
- You get used to it really fast.
- Yeah, and then it
gets, it actually gets,
you become gross and you don't know it.
You're like, "Oh gosh, I'm out of it"
and then you just use...
You do things that you
never thought you would do,
and you're like, "It's fine."
So do you have any parenting
advice for him, Selma?
- You know there is
Everybody tells you it goes so fast,
and there's moments when you go,
"That's not true, this
is going quite slow.
You know, I want her to talk to me,
I want to communicate."
And it's actually so true
because all of a sudden,
it just goes so fast and
you can never get it back
so really cherish every moment,
record, write things about it.
Are you having a boy or a girl?
- I'm having a girl. I wanted a girl.
- Oh, very bad time
- That's so cute, a girl,
dad I love your smile
- What an exciting
time, I loved decorating
the room, I loved all that